hello and welcome to the new world
review where I have decided never to
give Liam reason to use this photograph
again frankly I don't know why this
photo keeps turning up but it's the most
horrifying thing I can think of even
more horrifying than this this and this
you're used to me scaring you insulting
you ranting at you and generally
displeasing you so today I'm going to
provide you with this particular image
and hope that Liam is kind enough not to
use the same one repeatedly for the next
five minutes especially since this
person right here is not in fact
featured in Hunter hunter if you to
dislike Liam's use of this image please
hit the like button wait no let's
discuss episodes 25 and 27 oh yes I
skipped one because it was a recap okay
spoilers episode 25 something I haven't
discussed up till now is the new opening
we have and something I didn't really
discuss originally was the opening we
had we've stepped away from the concept
of hunting or hunters for a little bit
and we're in a tourist video it seems
strange to be in a tourist video but up
till now maybe that's appropriate we've
got some teenagers who we can only
assume contact their homes and important
people sorry karappa cut regularly to
tell them they're alive I mean really
what kind of world do we live in where
no one checks on the 10 year old to see
if he's even alive at this point I don't
care if he sends letters home what's
going on what kind of world is this in
general one where it's okay to breed
children for hunting if hisoka's to be
believed with his creepy under the bed
face
I enjoyed the tourist slot as it happens
I like that we hear what the world
outside of hunters and assassins would
see if they were to look at the map and
try to learn about the dark side it's
like us in the real world learning about
the Mafia no we don't want to actually
engage with the Mafia or the dark web
ooh dark web but it's enough to know it
exists
I do wonder given that we're showing the
silhouettes of Kiowas family whether
they know milky music whether they know
mierqi exists as someone experiencing
lactose intolerance I know I have
concerns about the names given to these
characters we'll come back to that later
it's also interesting looking at those
silhouettes that were given the
silhouettes despite the fact that we see
who they are almost immediately unlike
the original hunters in the Phantom
trope troupe phantom people thinking
about it more in terms of the world we
live in
kill
despite living a life where physical
abuse is literally commonplace and
expected is the only one whose family
actually sought him out not only that
but he's family the only one so far who
have actually taken the time to bring
him home or direct him on a path that
sure is incredibly dangerous and
psychopathic but sort of makes sense
despite everything they obviously care
about him it's a very strange unit to
see but the fact of the matter is that
it's a unit and that unit moves beyond
just the close family it seems the
butler's all of them are at least the
tooth lines also care about him his
mother is someone I simply don't
understand on the one hand she seems to
adore him on the other she seems to love
him there's nothing normal about the
lives they live and maybe it's because
they are assassins and they can only
trust each other since everyone else
wants them dead for sure but I found
myself feeling bad for her losing
essentially her favorite son canary is
staying behind also seemed to sadden her
too but since she had a hand in freeing
him perhaps that little smile at the end
means it's worth it I found it really
interesting how well they could show her
emotion on her face given it was
entirely animated and still and I
appreciated that in fact when I look
back on it it's quite funny that she was
the only one whose face was visible
among those really really tall people
what is it about her that they hired a
very short clearly juvenile person to be
a butler at this Manor anyway I spent a
whole episode on her let's move on we
found out what Hisoka Hisoka said
karateka and it was not about gone how
foolish and wrong I was silly past me
turns out he knew something about the
arachnid crud paired up turns out he
knew something about the arachnid
corridor was yes
ker-rah Hilda I'm smart was it because
he was perfectly calm at the time but he
was perfectly calm when dude brought
back in the jail said it even though he
knew dudebro was not one of the Phantom
spiders trope troupe phantom troupe
phantom I'll get names eventually gone
slicing his own eye was horrific mostly
because when I see things like that I
imagine what it would feel like that
said I do also very much enjoy coin
tricks and trying to guess which hand a
coin is in Liam may well not know this I
love that game now he knows I guess they
got killer back boys a back in town
ah boys a bet in town boys at back in
town except they're not because the team
split off immediately gone and cue I
have to find a gravity machine and maybe
boomer has won oh I'm excited for the
crossover because I'm really hoping they
don't just leave us hanging with an
entire season before we get to pick up
these storylines again I sense the
training montage between all three maybe
an episode each to see how they're going
the audio gets to go to cram school and
he has his own shoot see slice-of-life
anime while Korra pika joins some kind
of Fight Club that he could never speak
up again but does because he's karateka
at least that's what I would do with
this series I also really have to say
why why your new city I'm I just
your new let's move on it's such
low-hanging fruit I'm not even going to
episode 27 and it seems like any hope of
a quick montage has been shattered
because who cares about the audio and
karateka when we can talk about cute
little martial arts boy and run in a
nanana nanana nanana nanana nanana
and you like you like you like you like
you are my favorite moment if the entire
episode was killer saying I want to
learn about Renan in because it might
give me clues about my brother and then
rates are basically saying and gone was
also there it was hilarious and
entertaining it was also a tiny moment
at the end and really wasn't the only
thing I liked so let's look at the rest
of the episode people have been under
estimating these kids from the beginning
of the show so it's not a surprise to me
that they enter a tournament no child
has any business being a part of and are
immediately dismissed by everyone but a
smaller stronger child the sudden yell
and the come home with me little boys
and I'll teach you how to be bigger
faster stronger better don't do it but
also do because it's time kilwa wasn't
affected by his brother and then maybe
he could go back and finish the hunter
Hunter hunter hunter exam no just the
hunter exam finished the hunter exam and
returned home to be the true king of
Pride Mountain the way his father always
wanted him to be I believe in you QR
despite the number of storage tropes I
just touched on I actually do think he
was pretty amazing and I would actually
like to see what happens when he does
get strong enough to have a showdown
with his brother when he does finish the
hunter exam though that one seems much
less likely for some reason when he does
become the true king of chicken ville
and rule the roost after beating down
his tiger dad and panicky I glow mother
but what exactly is the significance of
cute fish boy
he's kind of adorable in his little ghee
in his serious eyes if I'm gonna learn
to beat people up with care and
attention see my stance as I prepare to
now look at me while i enhance my energy
and become the one thing you'll bounce
back away from haha you scared q ah good
maybe you should be that is my
impression of little zhu xi so you know
i'm glad they have another kid to get
mad at all curious about but at the same
time it still seems unlikely that all
these kids are gonna be in the same
league or even that they would appear in
sushi in fact stronger faster better
bigger whatever that song's adjectives
are he doesn't turn up in the brand-new
opening credits don't think I missed
that although I am very percept
his trainer didn't either
which means we are and will just pass
through this time probably fairly
quickly though I do wonder sometimes
whether it's less about the important
people and more about the strong people
when they choose who to show maybe zhu
xi and his trainer will turn up later
down the line in a future art as the set
up seems to be come with me if you want
to learn i doubt it but i have been
wrong before maybe once or twice don't
get ideas liam what i liked about the
opening credits liam hates that i do
this out of orders right as i think
sorry guys was that the actual lyrics
changed to reflect where we are in the
story i knew because i often sing along
and that Hisoka turns up he still turns
up anyway despite being somewhat
unhealthy it was clear to me that the
credits have been updated to show what's
ahead while also tipping a hat to all
the things that weren't resolved in the
first season and since the characters
are eventually going to have to go to
york new it makes sense to me that the
past trauma would appear in the present
credits we're not focused on gone for
this arc though i sense
the focus shifting let's talk about the
moment q what did bounce back yes it was
an immediate response to zhu xi's
intention changing in the same way that
illumise did and that's been made very
clear but we never truly see the end of
that fight yes it's entirely likely that
Keeler did win and zhu xi lost in time
something about the way the cut happened
was interesting why stop there why not
show kill while conquering that fear
even briefly with chicken wing of stop
zhu xi using his wreden in in in if kylo
I had been an adult and can we look at
all these food names please me turkey
sushi chicken wing look I added the
chicken but we also do have cluck
chicken e Mountain what's going on here
is this actually a play on Dragon Ball Z
since we're just learning to power up
this family is important but we seem to
have very quickly passed through a
transitional phase between arcs and are
now in a phase of powerup I'd say we're
still in an arc of training but the
story here seems fuzzy an episode ago
the characters were looking for Kiowa
and the important thing was Kiowas
family this still feels like an arc
about Kilwa but it's a little loose I
don't know where we're going despite
having heard Liam saying then several
times and
there are videos like this one this one
and this one on the channel even if I
haven't watched them nan is a thing
don't know about Ren which is why I keep
going on and it's also quite fun to say
if you say it to yourself in it anyway I
have no idea what that thing is it's a
thing with a capital T that is very much
known in the culture of hunter hunter
I'm hoping it becomes clearer soon it's
something that seems to happen a lot in
this series we float around not a bed of
concepts for a while then touch down on
hard-hitting story for a few episodes
before floating up again it's not that I
can't handle conceptual ideas it's that
when that's all I'm getting it's hard to
feel that what I'm watching is all
connected and I need it to be connected
and significant for me to engage with it
fully I will hope that things get
clearer very soon which maybe they will
when they get to the strange man's house
and you know what that sounds like a
perfect place to stop don't go into
strangers houses stay in yours instead
visit the discord server hit like or the
dislike button and maybe go here or here
or watch this thing or do this thing
instead am I getting it right buttons
clickable things this has been the grin
line review tell me your thoughts and
episodes 25 and 26 of Hunter hunter and
I'll have more things like this for you
to click next time